she's the whole package you know singing
acting beauty
she's got it all singing acting beauty
and now a bun in the oven that's right a
source tells e.t
katherine mcphee and david foster are
expecting their first child together
and are very excited it's super super
cool
et's source adds quote catherine and
david discuss having kids early on and
we're on the same page
this will be the 36 year old american
idol alums
first child while the 70 year old music
icon has
5 daughters from previous relationships
34 year old jordan
38 year old aaron 39 year old sarah
46 year old amy and 50 year old alison
the former smash star and the record
producer got married in
june 2019 it's the second marriage for
catherine and the
fifth for david she was previously
married to nick cocas from 2008 to 2016
while david was previously married to bj
cook rebecca dyer
linda thompson and yolanda hadid on
their wedding day catherine penned a
sweet message on instagram quote
exactly 13 years ago today my very first
single somewhere over the rainbow
was released right after idol today i'm
marrying the man who produced it
life is full of beautiful coincidences
isn't it thank you for taking me over
the rainbow david
uh how hollywood happily ever after is
that
we just really love being with each
other there's no arguing no like drama
it's just
easy so that's how it should be